I ran the polygraph examinations
thousands of them between 1972 and 1979
and I never once believed that the
polygraph was capable of detecting
deception fear has a definite distinct
smell a combination of [ __ ] and speech
for seven years I would smell that fear
every day in my office it was there when
I closed up the office every night and
it was there to greet me the next
morning when I entered the office
polygraph is not a test it's an intense
interrogation and the only part the
polygraph plays is to frighten and
intimidate a person into making a
confession or an admission it doesn't
record truth or deception there is no
such thing as a lying reaction it
records nervousness the reaction that
would brand you as a liar only indicates
deception about 50% of the time
anybody can pass any lie-detector test
by simply duplicating the physiological
response to fear on demand at the
appropriate time what the polygraph
records is your blood pressure your
pulse rate
it also shows what's called the galvanic
skin response that's where electrodes
are placed on the first and third
fingers of your right hand and it
records the sweat activity in your hand
and there are new McGrath tubes placed
around your chest and stomach that
record your breathing any number of
innocent stimuli can and do cause the
exact same reaction that would brand you
as a liar the more well-developed your
sense of conscience the more likely you
are to flunk a polygraph examination and
the more of an old thief and the more
hardened to your conscience the better
your chances are passing it take a
quarter out of your pocket and flip that
sucker if it's heads they're lying
if its tail's they're telling the truth
that's exactly the same degree of
accuracy that this polygraph instrument
has
in order to pass a polygraph examination
you have to understand how polygraph is
scored there are two different types of
questions relevant and control now the
relevant questions are obviously those
that pertain to the pointed issue is
your first name Jenna yes did you tell
the complete truth on your job
application yes control questions then
are interspersed have you ever stolen
anything have you ever lied to anyone
who trusted you besides what you've told
me have you ever lied to get out of
trouble no you have to show no reaction
whatsoever on the relevant questions
here's your first name Jana that's your
first relevant nice and calm and even no
major fluctuations at all and you have
to show a reaction on the control
questions because what they do is they
compare your reactions now here's your
first control question see how high that
GSR went out you rate the breathing you
can tell lack take that across the
street you can tell which question
bothered you and here's relevant again
nice and calm nice and calm nice and
calm now how do you do this so utterly
simple on all the relevant questions you
think about laying on the beach and
watching the waves gently rolling into
the shore thinking nice calm relaxing
thoughts is there anything in your
background that would disqualify you
from getting this job No
on the control questions you think about
falling off of a building and smashing
your guts out on that sidewalk below
besides what you've told me have you
ever stolen anything else no thinking
that frightening scenario induces a
stress reaction that causes a reaction
on the control questions no reaction on
the relevance reaction on the controls
pass can't be beat for the past 35 years
I have dedicated my life to exposing the
waste fraud and abuse in the polygraph
industry and as a reward the government
is now trying to imprison me for upwards
of a hundred years and find me a million
and a half dollars
how dare you file federal criminal
charges against me for protesting the
use of this polygraph and demonstrating
what a ridiculous instrument it is the
devil hates to be mocked and I'm mocking
them every chance I get
exposing them for frauds con men and
manipulative bastards